the united states has announced a
diplomatic boycott of the beijing winter
olympics over china's human rights
record the measure should not impact u.s
athletes competing in the games next
year but china's government has
threatened to take countermeasures
the snow making machines are working
full blast as the chinese test their
winter venues weeks before the calendar
says it's winter but less than two
months before the start of the 2022
winter games
athletes around the world have been
sharpening their skills even as human
rights advocates call for a total
boycott of the games pointing to the
internment camps in xinjiang province
where they say china has allegedly
detained up to a million muslim uyghurs
against their will
the white house finally decided on a
softer approach u.s athletes should
compete u.s diplomats should stay home
the biden administration will not send
any diplomatic or official
representation to the beijing 2022
winter olympics and paralympic games
given the pierre scenes ongoing genocide
and crimes against
humanity in xinjiang and other human
rights abuses
the chinese foreign ministry knew this
might be coming and earlier in the day
tried to preempt the diplomatic boycott
without being invited
american politicians keep hyping the
so-called diplomatic boycott of the
beijing winter olympics which are purely
wishful thinking and grandstanding
political manipulation is a blatant
insult of the spirit of the olympic
charter and an outright political
provocation
the dispatching of high-level
delegations to each olympics and
paralympics is a tradition for the u.s
and other leading nations first lady
jill biden attended the tokyo games this
summer
u.s delegation seats will be empty this
february though china is certain to say
they were never invited anyway
our washington correspondent carolina
chamoy has been looking into whether
other countries are planning a similar
boycott
that is precisely what the united states
would like to see secretary of state
anthony blinken he said that the u.s has
been consulting with allies and partners
on a shared approach to the beijing
games because of their concern about
china's human rights record um and the
chief of the european union's diplomatic
service here in washington dc he said
last week after some meetings with u.s
officials that it was important to keep
up pressure on china indeed over the
abuses in xinjiang but that anybody
caught was in the domain and if the the
hands of each country and not uh it was
not a common position of the european
union on foreign policy and chinese
state media have said that beijing does
not intend to invite western politicians
who have threatened a boycott actually
russian president vladimir putin he is
the only leader of a major country who
has accepted china's invitation to
attend these games